Speaker 1: We start today with the beginning
of the Dominion voting systems, Fox News defamation
trial.
This is a trial that could have such far ranging
impact, and we're going to be watching it
extraordinarily closely.
Now, the trial was originally scheduled to
start yesterday.
There was the announcement that there would
be a delay and there was the suspicion that
the delay might be because Fox News wanted
to settle the case and prevent it from going
to trial.
Whether or not that's what the cause of the
delay was, the case is not being settled and
the trial is set to start today.
CNBC reports Fox News and Dominion trial kicks
off with opening statements in defamation
suit.
Dominion has accused Fox of intentionally
and falsely blaming it for President Donald
Trump's loss to Joe Biden by airing false
claims that the company rigged the 2020 election.
Fox has maintained the statements made about
dominion on air are protected by the First
Amendment.
The case has led to the release of troves
of private messages and testimony from top
Fox News figures, including Fox Corporation
Chairman Rupert Murdoch and opinion host Tucker
Carlson.
So is a couple different things here that
are of absolutely critical importance.
First of all, the mere fact that Fox News
is asserting First Amendment protection isn't
unique, and it's really important to understand
that there are many circumstances in which
there is defamation alleged.
And as a defense, the First Amendment is given.
That doesn't make this case special.
It doesn't particularly make it about actually
factual free speech.
This is a case in which you are alleging defamation,
meaning incorrect claims knowingly made which
are harmful to the reputation in this case
of dominion with the counter point that you
can always issue as a defense to defamation
the truth of the claims made if it were true
that Trump won in 2020, but because of a rigging
done involving Dominion voting systems, Joe
Biden became president.
If you could demonstrate that, then it would
by definition not be defamation.
And we're going to get back to that in a moment.
We are going to see, among other things, likely
even more documents and text messages and
communications come out.
These are the very communications through
which we learned that there are some true
believers on Fox News staff, including people
like Maria BARTIROMO, that there are people
on Fox News staff like Tucker Carlson, who
despised Donald Trump passionately was the
word Tucker used to describe his hate for
Donald Trump.
And on some level, this is sort of a lose
lose for Fox now that it's gotten to this
point.
And what I mean by that is if Fox were to
settle, they might avoid what now might be
4 to 6 weeks of disastrous headlines as more
evidence comes out in the trial.
But they would be, to some degree, admitting
guilt.
And the alternative is, well, you don't settle,
but you now have six weeks of potentially
disastrous headlines and at the end of it,
you still might lose a whole bunch of money
and your reputation could be irreparably damaged.
Now, to get back to that, a defense to defamation
is proving the facts.
Donald Trump's suggestion, which he posted
yesterday or the day before yesterday, we
talked about it yesterday, the truth, social
truth.
Speaker 2: Central.
Speaker 1: Was that Fox indeed do that and
say, hey, it's not defamation.
Trump really won.
Trump's idea posted on troth central in all
capital letters was quote, If Fox would finally
admit that there was large scale cheating
and irregularities in the 2020 presidential
election, which would be a good thing for
them and for America, the case against them,
which should not have existed at all, would
be greatly weakened.
Backup those patriots at Fox instead of throwing
them under the bus.
And they are right.
There is so much proof like mass ballot stuffing
caught on government cameras, FBI colluding
with Twitter and Facebook, state legislatures
not used, etc..
Now, there's a couple interesting things about
this.
First of all, as I mentioned, defamation is
a legal term, false statements harmful to
someone's reputation.
Someone accuses you of defamation.
One defense is prove that what you said is
true.
The problem with Trump's idea, other than
the fact that Trump didn't win the November
of 2020 election and so you can't prove something
that's not true.
This particular case is narrowly focused on
the allegedly defamatory statements made about
Dominion voting systems involvement.
Many of the things Trump is talking about
here ballot stuffing, FBI colluding with Twitter.
Even if Fox tried to prove that in this trial,
it wouldn't be a useful defense because the
allegations in.
Question that are allegedly defamatory are
the ones about Dominion voting systems specifically.
Imagine the circus that that would be, though.
Fox News didn't defame anyone because Trump
did win and Dominion voting Systems did do
whatever Mike Pillow says that they did with
the machines.
Like imagine the circus that that would become
side story here.
That's an important story that I do want to
mention as well.
Angelo Carusone from Media Matters, who we've
interviewed on the program, he has a really
good Twitter thread explaining an additional
issue for Fox News that could be disastrous.
And we'll link to the Twitter thread in the
description for the YouTube video where I'm
talking about this.
Angelo writes that parallel to this trial,
Fox News is going to be renegotiating and
gearing up to renegotiate renewals on Xfinity
Charter and Cox.
These are three different cable carriers.
Fox News is the only commercial news.
And even you could even go further than that
commercial TV channel that doesn't actually
need ads because they make a lot of their
money.
Because if you have a cable subscription,
even if you don't like Fox News, even if you
don't watch Fox News, some of your monthly
bill goes directly to Fox News behind ESPN.
Fox News is the second most expensive channel
on every cable bill.
You can't change that.
Consider the situation where you now have
a beleaguered Fox News, to put it lightly,
in the middle of a defamation trial.
And they are going to have to go and negotiate
with these cable carriers and say we want
the same amount of money per subscriber that
you're giving us now, or we want even more
money per subscriber than you're giving us
now.
And a lot of these subscribers are going to
look at Fox potentially and say, Hey, wait
a second.
It's not even really clear.
Much of our customer base wants your channel.
Here's evidence that not that many people
are watching.
And in addition, you guys are hugely damaged
right now.
We don't even know what the future is.
A Fox News.
The last thing we're going to do is commit
to paying however many dollars a month you
want us to pay.
This is a parallel story to the Dominion lawsuit
that could be a disaster for Fox News, and
we're going to be watching it as well.
The trial will not be televised.
Many people writing to me saying, David will
it will be streamed live.
It will not.
But there will be reporters in the courtroom
and we are going to get daily updates.
Let's see how the first day goes.